hey what's up guys my name is China
welcome back to my OpenGL series so last
time we talked about projection matrices
and we basically over the last few
episodes have gotten a math library into
our application here that we're building
in OpenGL so today what I want to talk
about is I guess the next step after the
projection matrix so we have projection
matrices and specifically we implemented
like an orthographic projection for our
view if we just launch a program from
the last time so that we can see what we
actually had we managed to draw this
channelago kind of in the in a different
position not in the center and at the
correct aspect ratio by using an
orthographic projection which we
provided over here in this line of code
so that's kind of one face of it the
projection matrix but there's also two
other matrices are fairly important when
we're dealing with the transformation of
geometry when we render it in a scene so
the first being projection but then we
also have something called a view matrix
and we have something called a model
matrix as well and that all of that gets
multiplied together with our with each
vertex position to give us kind of the
final position of the vertex in our
actual screen like on inside our window
or in our kind of 2d projection that is
on our computer screen so again lots of
theory behind this which I probably will
cover at some point but what I want to
do today is just kind of introduce the
concept and actually show you guys how
you can access it and what it's used for
and then you can kind of play around
with that and hopefully learn it that
way because that's probably a better way
of learning it they're just studying a
lot of theory and not doing anything ok
so let's get straight into it model view
projection MVP or in you know if you
reverse it PVM i guess but usually it's
set as MVP and you may have heard that
term as well MVP or MVP matrix so that
stands for model view projection matrix
and that is kind of the transformation
pipeline that hat that goes through
every vertex now I keep saying pipeline
but really what I mean is that each one
of those letters MVP is a separate four
by four matrix and that and all those
matrices get multiplied together in that
order Model View projection now in
OpenGL since we deal with column-major
ordering it's actually done in kind of
Reverse ish like
if we were to write it out in inside our
shader code or inside out GLM code in
C++ here it would be projection times of
U times model whereas like indirect tax
in direct3d because they didn't deal
with row major order information C's it
would actually be MVP Model View
projection you'd actually have your
vertex positions on the left side of
that kind of equation non left side of
the equation but that would be kind of
the first thing you multiply if you read
left to right but as an open jealous
reverse so the fact that if MVP doesn't
necessarily define the order lots of
stuff we could talk about here that we
probably don't need to mention but the
idea is that we have these three
matrices and they kind of define
different things for our vertex
positions because what happens in the
end is we multiplied all the matrices
together and we multiplied that matrix
that resulting matrix with our vertex
position and that vertex position is the
vertex position of our geometry which is
stored inside our vertex buffer and that
kind of all that multiplication
transforms that vertex into where it
should be on our actual screen on our
computer screen that's what this is all
for so we have the projection matrix
which we talked about last time which
was specifically for actually converting
this kind of whatever space we choose to
work with into normalized device
coordinates meaning we're converting
from whatever space we're dealing with
and whether that be orthographic or
perspective into a negative one to one
mapping in kind of every axis and x y&z
that's what the projection matrix is
responsible for definitely check out
that video if you happen already the
model and the view matrix are something
a little bit different the view matrix
sometimes called the eye matrix is kind
of the view of the camera so it's a way
for us to kind of simulate a camera more
or less and then be model matrix is a
way for us to basically simulate the
model matrix so the model being the
model that we're actually drawing so the
vertex that we're drawing and the matrix
specifically is just a transformation of
the model so to put this into more
simple terms projection aside because
that
kind of defines like I guess what kind
of space we deal with the view matrix is
the position the rotation scale whatever
of our camera and then the model matrix
is the position there's the rotated
transform so the the position rotation
scale of our actual model the returning
of our object so we have the object
transform and we have the cameras
transform now it's important to
understand that at the end of the day
these are just mathematical numbers the
fact that I've kind of given you this
illustration of we have a camera we have
this model kind of transformation matrix
that's all kind of an illusion in the
sense that you don't like you don't have
to have a camera you could just I don't
know just you could just have your
camera in the center at all times and
just have the kind of model matrix and
that will work as well because really
these are just numbers and they all get
multiplied together anyway you can have
another matrix that's like your
secondary camera matrix or whatever
there's so many ways you could do this
because it doesn't really matter
they're just you're multiplying matrices
together you have to understand that
it's as simple as that
so the convention that we kind of deal
with is we have a view matrix that is
specifically supposed to represent our
cameras kind of position and orientation
and then we have a model matrix which is
supposed to represent our objects
transform object being the thing that
we're currently drawing because what
will happen is we're going to multiply
the projection matrix with the camera
matrix with the model matrix with the
vertex position and we'll take a look at
that in a minute but conceptually I just
want you to understand that what I'm
introducing here are two different
matrices the view matrix and the model
matrix the view matrix is supposedly
supposed to represent our camera
position and orientation and the model
matrix is supposed to represent our
objects transform meaning by transform
by transform and I probably will make
your videos specifically on this as well
teaching OpenGL is hardman okay I'm
gonna make a video on that as well but
transform specifically means
[Music]
position rotation scale or translation I
should say that's the word I was looking
for it's been a long day man
translation is translation rotation
scale TRS translation meaning the kind
of the position I guess of our object
the rotation of being the what
orientation is kind of rotated in and
the scale being kind of how big or small
it is doesn't have to be uniform scaling
either so my you might be able to change
like if it's a cube you could make it a
like a rectangular prism or something
like that and we'll definitely get into
that in the future as well
but that is the idea anyway I'm gonna
stop talking because I'm feel like I'm
just gonna ramble on for another 18
hours let's just get into this and see
what we can do with this newfound
knowledge so at the moment what we have
is kind of our base vertex positions
which are over here we've created a
vertex a sorry a projection matrix that
is an orthographic matrix that is kind
of from 0 to 9 16 from 0 to 540 so in
other words it's kind of a pixel space
projection here because every unit is
one pixel here are our vertex positions
and those are just inside our vertex
buffer and what we're doing here
well this result was just kind of me
simulating that that multiplication on
the CPU side but if you look at what our
shader is doing it's also doing that in
the sense that is taking our MVP our
Model View projection matrix that we're
passing in here and multiplying it with
position now if we take a look at what
MVP actually is here you can see that
what we actually passing here is just
this project we're just passing in that
projection matrix we're not actually
won't have any kind of view matrix or
model matrix but what we're going to do
now is we're going to add a view matrix
and what this is going to be is the
position of our camera so at this point
we need to decide well how do we want to
move our camera maybe we want to
translate our camera we won't worry
about rotation just to give this simple
for now let's maybe move our camera out
of no hundred units to the left now
here's a trick what we're doing here is
we're trying to move our camera so let's
kind of for a minute for a brief minute
because I will have a separate video
as for a brave male let's just thinking
about what a camera is well okay there's
no it's not actually like a camera
doesn't extra actually exist is no such
thing as a camera so how would we
simulate a camera well let's just say we
have an object on this phone over here
right we have a camera here so if I want
to move the camera to the left then the
object would move to the right
technically speaking so if I can't move
the camera to the left then the object
kind of moves to the right that's what
happens I you probably can't see much
and then I probably should just draw a
diagram but that's kind of what I'm
getting at if you like the cat there's
no such thing as a camera in OpenGL all
we can really do real really is just
move geometry around we can move
vertices around so to simulate a camera
moving left what we really need to do is
move everything to the right so it's
kind of the reverse operation here so
what I'm going to do here is create a
translation matrix except since I want
to move everything to the right hundred
units what I'm actually going to write
here is a vector E where I'm just moving
everything negative 100 or such is left
because that will kind of be like moving
the camera to the right and I'll just
fill in zero for the other units here
and let's see what else is wrong
so I guess what we should really
probably do here is actually just create
a an identity view matrix which would
mean one of these and then translate
that matrix by just doing that and I
believe that should change it now it
takes a Const which is great so we'll
actually have to what we could do I
guess is probably end up constructing a
identity matrix here and then assigning
it to view like that all right cool so
that's kind of our view matrix so now
what we'll do is this MVP thing will
actually create a GLM map for MVP matrix
which will be that projection times the
view now so let's pass that in to MVP
here and hit f5 to run our program all
right cool and so the result here is
that this
has just moved a hundred units to the
left because what we've done is we've
moved our camera to the right and if we
move our camera to the right it means
that everything else now seemed kind of
removed to the left and I've simulated
that by just doing the reverse operation
here because I'm typing in negative 100
here which essentially ends up moving
the object to the left which again is a
simulation of moving the camera to the
right so that's how that works obviously
if you had a camera class you'll kind of
this kind of negation you'll automate
all that and the API will take care of
that for you so you don't have to worry
about that but mathematically that's how
it works
moving the camera to the left is
actually just moving all the objects to
the right so with this same principle
because all we've really done here I
mean you can't tell the difference I've
called it view matrix but you can't tell
the difference between us moving the
camera to the left or asked moving the
object to the right the same thing so
it's again purely a kind of way to
visualize how this actually works but
mathematically it's just it's all the
same it's just numbers so what we'll do
now is we'll create this model matrix
and I'll again translate the model
somewhere so we ended up translating
this well the camera we're moving to the
right so what I'll do here maybe is move
the model up a bit so maybe it will say
when we have a 200 to the right and 200
up and so we should it but we should
basically end up with our channel logo
being closer to this to the to the
center of the screen and we'll multiply
all these matrices together so
projection times view times model hit f5
and you can see now we have the channel
logo being moved another you know 200
units up and 200 units to the right okay
and that's what we end up with cool so
this the resulting matrix here is what
our MVP is Model View projection and
again the multiplication is kind of in
reverse order that's to do with the fact
the memory layout of all the numbers
that are there in column major you can
kind of think of reading matrix
multiplication in OpenGL as
right-to-left
so we multiply model with viewed with
projection that's just how it ends up
working out because of the way that
we've laid out our memory because of the
way that OpenGL actually expects it in
the
in the GPU and also the way the GLM
handles it for us because of that kind
of specification by OpenGL but anyway
that's what you see here three matrices
multiplied together which create the
transformation for our vert for our
actual vertices that is very simple
camera multiply it with the transform of
our object multiplied with that
projection which converts everything
into normalized device coordinates that
is basically all the matrix
multiplication you need to know if
you're worried about positioning objects
in a 3d or 2d world that's it that's all
there is to know obviously you can do
more than just translation I kind of
just showed you with simple example now
what I want to do next time because
we've kind of touched on all this kind
of model your projection stuff in this
episode which is awesome
next time I want to actually start
introducing a perspective projection and
maybe get into some 3d stuff now because
it's going to be really important for us
to have some kind of way of controlling
these parameters live because I can't
keep closing my application changing the
code recompiling it and updating it
that's gonna be really painful and
really hard for me to demonstrate
anything like that what I'm actually
going to do is probably integrate I am
GUI which is a kind of a UI framework
really easy to use UI kind of layer that
we can use for actually kind of having
UI controls as part of our our
application which we can use to modify
variables while our application is
running it's kind of like a debug layer
really easy kind of UI to use so we'll
probably integrate that next time but
other than that we're just gonna
progress keep going with this kind of
math stuff and hopefully get into
perspective projections soon and think
about how we can render real-world kind
of objects on the screen whether that be
3d or 2d we might go back and forth
between 3d and 2d you haven't decided
yet but that is kind of the gist of this
let me know what you guys thought of
this whole movie projection thing I am
going to probably end up making more
detailed videos about each concept but I
kind of like to make an overall video
discovery just introducing the topic
first because this is probably enough
information for all of you to actually
start doing this yourself and play
around with
and that's gonna be probably the best
way to learn anyway I hope you guys
enjoy this video if you did you hit that
like button you can go ahead and help
support the series by going patreon icon
4/2 channel huge thank you as always to
all the wealthy patrons who make this
series possible it wouldn't be here
without you
I will see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]